[Music]
[Applause]
all right we're waiting word from the
Big 10 and then how Michigan responds is
Jim Harbaugh going to be on the
sidelines this weekend does any of this
punishment matter or the rumors of it or
the possibility I think it's all if it
happens it happens in the off season but
let's bring in Rick neiser our good
buddy CBS sports college football
analyst former college coach at udub
also Colorado and UCLA all right Rick
what do you think should happen to Jim
Harbaugh and
Michigan uh I just put this under the
category of overzealous The Wizard of Oz
right this is uh you got a guy by the
name of Connor stallion who just super
fan wants to impress the head coach and
finds ways to get all kinds of
intelligence the head coach goes wait a
minute you really can get that stuff and
proves to be very accurate information
and you end up hiring him and the guy
went way over skis and obviously didn't
do a very good job of hiding his Trail
uh as we're uncovering more and more of
this yeah this is just overzealousness
101 what will happen do you think well
you've got a bunch of angry coaches you
got a real bunch of angry an angry mob
right now knocking at the door and uh
you know Tony petiti is in a bind
because he's got to prove to these guys
that he's going to try to find some
measure of justice and Michigan's going
to just lawyer up this is going to get
pushed to the after the season because
of all the legal machinations and uh I
would guess that Jim Harbaugh will be
looking for a work in the
NFL and you talked about that a couple
of weeks that's what you thought would
maybe be the end result here but also
you were on you were coaching what three
different programs and did you ever have
anybody who would have gone Rogue on you
and got gathered information that you
didn't know about to maybe help your
assistant coaches not that I'm aware of
now listen we all I know there's some
push back now by Michigan that coaches
are you know conspiring and getting
information against Michigan you'd
always get on the phone and ask somebody
who's a friend in the business if they
just played somebody give me you know
your tells right if you're going into a
poker game you want to know what
people's uh tells are that that happens
all the time but to go to the level that
Conor stallion is apparently gone to uh
I have never been aware of anything like
that did you ever get signals did you
ever get information like that from
another coach sharing information like
ruers Purdue in Ohio State are accused
of doing the signals that you would
always try to get from opponents is
Personnel groups defensive coordinators
are hellbent to find out what personnels
going into the game especially with this
Advent of uptempo stuff so if you're
changing personnel and you're going from
11 personnel which means one back and
and uh one tight end in the game and
you're going to now 10 Personnel taking
the tight end out and adding a wide
receiver the the coordinator the
defensive coordinator the play caller
wants to know that information so that
he can give a call that's more in touch
with all the the data that you have when
in when they're in 10 so you're always
looking to see what signals are going in
to communicate that yeah I'm just trying
to figure out the role like did Ohio
State ruter in Purdue what they're
accused of is that illegal they're no
what I think they're getting is the sign
are are Personnel groupings I think
they're just getting Personnel grouping
signals I don't think they're they're
they have the uh the wherewithal to
figure out what the play call is I I
really don't what what uh what Conor
stallions was doing was taking it to the
nth degree and knowing everything there
was to know about the stuff and at least
allegedly and uh coordinators is all the
video shows him standing next to the
coordinators are waiting for him to say
run pass and what kind of run and pass
and that's a huge Advantage I'm just
trying to understand this though Rick if
I had somebody on my staff who was going
to other games getting information who's
he giving the information to and how
does Jim Harbaugh not know that somebody
on his staff is going to scout in
advance maybe be in Disguise and giving
that information to one of his assistant
coaches
I think uh that Jim did know I I I think
it's implausible for him not to know
that this guy has some real information
and some important data that can be
really useful to the coordinators in
their play calls uh and you know the
fact that he was out there doing all
this I don't think Jim wanted to know
how he was doing it but he was certainly
uh it was useful information which is
why the guy went from Super Fan to an
employee talking to Rick new Heisel CBS
sports college football analyst former
College head coach at Washington UCLA in
Colorado what is the policy etiquette of
ratting out a program like if you got
information you know would you share
that with somebody uh a reporter or the
nciaa if you knew that they were up to
something nefarious I think what we all
would like to say we would do is go
straight to the source which is mean if
you had a suspicion that Jim Harbaugh
was doing something you'd go straight to
Jim Harbaugh I know he did that to me he
thought I was he thought I was uh
involved with a recruit uh at a time
where I couldn't be on in in phone
conversation with him or I couldn't call
the recruit and he called me out and and
accused me of it I said Jim absolutely
not the kid called me uh it was a kid
out of Stockton by the name of Philip
rule a kind of walk- on fullback that
you know Walk-Ons couldn't get into
Stanford so this was a unique
uh guy for him so har calls you and says
oh yeah he called me every name in the
book saying I was cheating and I said
you're absolutely out of your mind I not
I've got all the phone records you can
see that Phil rule called me wanting to
come to UCLA but we had it out on the
phone there was nothing going back uh
give and take what what's amazing Dan
this this guy went to the lengths of
bring all this data we were back in the
pack 10 at the time and uh wanted uh
Pete Carroll to stop having the use of
all the Pack 12 officials at his
practice
he said he only had a budget for you
know three or four practices a year
where the Pack 12 official pack 10
officials at the time would come to his
practice and Pete was having them every
day he could afford to have them every
day and he was going to get this you
know great uh favoritism from the
officials because he was going to create
these relationships and then Pete raised
his hand and said I was the most
penalized team in the league and
everybody started laughing everybody
started laughing and Jim got so angry he
said it's the principle of the thing and
it was just like one of these things but
that's what I'm I'm wondering his dad
was a legendary coach by the book coach
like that's the thing I keep coming back
to with
Harbaugh um yeah what he done this and
and maybe embarrassed his dad in the
process I I guess the ends justify the
means but this is wildly embarrassing
wildly embarrassing because this is a
team that frankly doesn't need it this
team is really good what he's got matter
of fact he couldn't he couldn't stop
tell me in Indianapolis at the uh Big 10
media days that this is this team's
going to break the record of George's
most draft choices going to the NFL he
thinks it's going to be somewhere in an
18 to 20 number would you rather know
what Harbaugh knew or who's the one that
started the
investigation this is where you this is
the Johnny Cochran I mean he's just he's
just if the glove doesn't fit right
you've got you've got a jury looking at
something that doesn't have anything to
do with this the bottom line is Conor
stallions was too obvious but but
somebody had it out for Harbaugh oh yeah
that that Line's a long
line that Line's a long line just to put
you on record you had nothing to do with
this I had nothing I just want to make
sure yeah no you had no knowledge of it
but but somebody absolutely not somebody
gift wrapped this to the
NCAA oh without question without
question and uh obviously they got wind
of it somehow someway there was uh a tip
that this somebody was doing this yeah
but teams don't turn in other teams
though because everybody's cheating Rick
aren't they if no no not everybody at
this level that's and I'll draw a line
there everybody's trying to get
information trying to get tells and if
you got a buddy that knows something
you're going to ask what what you know
but no one's going to the lengths that
Connor stallion went and now finding out
that Connor stallions went from you know
the Wizard of Oz Over zealous to an
employee now you're you're
substantiating his work and and there is
where you've got an issue but it writes
it writes his own song I mean this is
going to be a song Dan and I'll come
back and perform it here at some point
what's it going to be called oh Santa oh
no Jimmy's got you in a bind are you
blind Conor stallion's Trail not hard to
find Santa Ono just play the game of
legal
bum bum bum oh yeah it's going to write
itself thank you buddy good to talk to
you again my
friend he was ready for that I was just
asking the title of the song but new
Isel who's given us many many songs born
in the SEC I think might have been the
first one legendary but uh interesting
though his take that Harbaugh called him
when Harbaugh was at Stanford and Rick
was recruiting somebody that Stanford
was recruiting and uh he thought that
Jim did some Jim thought that Rick did
something illegal and then called him up
and new Heisel said I didn't call the
recruit he called me and the fact that
Jim would call him on that that's why I
keep coming back to this that if you're
Michigan you don't have to do this it's
like the Houston Astros everybody says
you know hey they're not cheating now
you didn't have to cheat back then you
were that good